my lovely gamespot people i am kevin van
orden i'm joined by alexa korea hey guys
and we are going to play some homeworld
remastered which is very exciting now
I'm long home world as one of my top 10
games of all time so I'll o'connell to
death but you're driving today i am
driving i haven't touched it i'm waiting
for the review code to come so that i
can start from scratch and none not have
anything sullied by beta things and yeah
so i'm getting excited but you're
driving today and i can be the one
that's all nostalgic about homeworld i'm
excited to get in a Cell forgot
homeworld this is beautiful this is so
what are we doing like what I haven't we
haven't really talked about this though
so what what is it that you're gonna be
playing for us today we're looking at
the original homeworld correct uh yes
this is a homeworld remastered its
homeworld one it's the redone version so
this is the new bit that this is the
holy redone one that gearbox so this is
what gearbox has been doing of course
the original created by relic one of if
not i mean blizzard aside possibly the
most possibly the most beloved RTS
developer ever because we've got home
world we've got we've got dawn of war of
course company of heroes and the
wonderful and underrated impossible
creatures which is a shame that so many
people have not played this game or even
in this asleep heard of it I love so
check out the new like this is even
really HD cutscenes very exciting that
way it looks very very nice and also
it's just I like to point out this isn't
out yet the beta is a return private
breasts beta so we have it we've had it
for about a week now and I've been
tooling around with it the game itself
comes out in February 25th so you don't
actually have to wait that long yes it's
out very soon and something to throw in
one of the reasons one of the many many
many many reasons why i love homeworld
is this is a
game that because a lot of people say oh
you can expect the mothership you can't
expect a you know a great story and a
real-time strategy game what would you
be you know what are you talking about
what what kind of crap is that ya know
shut up because this is this is the
prototypical you know art oh my god yeah
yeah this is the prototypical you know
RTS with a great story there there are
very few games that i would put on that
list i would say homeworld and homeworld
to homeworld cataclysm Cataclysm was the
the for the first game that was the
expansion that came out for the first
game probably even better story why's
that I'm just getting excited now I feel
like a weird fan boy so now we see the
the other big thing of course is this is
all in 3d yeah you have 3d space there
are other space RTS a--'s but a lot of
them take place on 2d planes so while
the animations take place and utilize
the 3ds base the the gameplay itself
does not yeah you know games like hedge
ammonia and some other space RTS is like
that out I feel like I'm speaking Greek
I wonder how many people even remember
some of these games that I'm talking I
want you excited this is exciting and
for new people I've never played a
homeworld 2 I played the first one and I
adored it I did till around in homeworld
2 and even if you're a first-timer like
I would say the game the tutorials that
gearbox have put in her actually really
really great so I think it's something
that any new we could easily dive into
um I'm gonna tool around while we're
talking talking about Homer look at all
my scouts you got 10 many of baby scouts
good too many send them out you're going
to also want to want to start mining
sometimes yeah but right now of course
you don't have a you know you don't have
access to your full array of things this
is your elector I need a probe I'm gonna
make two on the off chance that one gets
like like bites it before we get there
that'll happens you know your primary
scouting mechanism is sending out a
probe kind of look around for you
was a vaguer might be coming any minute
I have a I have a resource collector i
wonder if i need another one though is
it off mining already yeah maybe it
won't work maybe so well yeah I mean one
of the first things in any RTS is
usually to get your resource get your
economy moving fast yeah and luckily the
early the early missions and home worlds
it's not pro are fairly easy to take
care of there's my probe where'd it go
no this is like this i'm just looking
it's always funny that it's always fun
to watch somebody that doesn't really
play I know I don't normally play they
can play RTS is you get on top of
something yeah this uh just man yelling
there's no salvage Corvette there's my
research ship I would go ahead and make
sure that you've you're collecting so I
think you've got a resource collector
there eventually you might want to get
yeah there you go I'm gonna do some
salvaging over here so we can build more
my other my resource collectors going
back to the ship home world is very
relaxing it is relaxing um I think part
of that has to do with the amazing
soundtrack there you are mainly my probe
and I want it to go so you can hit that
way yeah totally there we go totally oh
and my probe setting up and I feel like
I'm going to mispronounce the the
homeworld composers name is Paul risque
Paul parce que é um just one of the most
amazing soundtracks ever it has a you
know what it's one of those things where
it has a little bit of a new agey sound
without being cliche and when when
battle starts and hopefully we'll see
battle and you'll get through wells get
some close-ups in there one of the great
things that will then happen is that
there we go one of you know the the
battle music will
cut in and it's full of like very nasal
sounding reeds and things like that like
it's it's very unexpected it's not
Spacey I guess you would say and that's
what makes it really special is that
they avoid all of those yeah all of
those cliches and the music it feels
like between the music and then the
pacing and sort of the calmness of
everything it feels like it's less like
oh it's Star Wars and we're flying
around shooting people and it's more
like we are it's like The Melancholy
journey of humanity sitting out to like
find answers and stuff and it's very
like somber and mellow it was exciting
that's kind of the that's your kind of
getting into the story with that up to
because of course that is exactly what's
happening in a sense you know you're out
there you know uh you know I'm boy
there's been a discovery you know it's
it's very clear that we are not right
now where we have come from ya know that
the discovery has has led us into the
stars going after as you know as the
title of the game says it going after
our home world oh my god shouts in there
the mothership
oh my God where the hell do they go
click on the red there they go I'm
trying to like zoom them all up getting
banged around here kabhi engaging there
we go got him get Iran Iran is let's
zoom in and take a look at those look at
me look at these light trails I mean the
game has always been I mean let's face
it homeworld and homeworld 2 already
looked amazing yeah and so medicine you
know it's it's really great to see it
updated but what I love is is that
they're already taking a game that holds
up so well visually show no mercy so I
just set all of my target all of my
scouts to be aggressive
so they're going to go after these ships
and shoes which is helpful you can also
create control groups called strike
groups now those are those are really
helpful you know the the old-fashioned
you know you know against control one to
group them together control too and so
forth and then you can switch easily
back without having the the
drag-and-drop there we go another one I
you know another one of my favorite
things you know about the game in
general is just the sound design it they
don't talk enough about sound now we
down in games it's easy to focus on the
visuals for obvious reasons but when
people tell me that they turn the sound
off and listen to music or something
that's always one of those things that
drives me just a little bit crazy haha
and assuming so we can really see what's
going on huh yeah I get rid of the 1i
there there's a I think the ft or
something like that should allow you to
focus on one ship and follow and follow
it around I don't remember exactly what
the there we go it's it's been a little
while since I've play at home world so
but I think you can click on one ship
and use the ft or something like that to
to follow it around and zoom in yeah
it's a lot of fancy maneuvering so I'm
gonna I i was now thankfully brought a
laptop so i'm looking at both the twitch
chat in the game spot comments are the
game spot chat so if you have any
questions just let me know we be a
little easy on Alexis she doesn't
typically play strategy games yeah so
she's tooling around while the rest of
us judge her nah I'm going after them
I'm really putting all my power into
getting rid of these little dude but
don't forget you have an economy so you
can build some fighters and I can't and
I think I will actually you've also got
your your research actually I want to
pull that out for a minute so you guys
can see this like this is incredible
like look at those light paths
the way that like gearboxes put this
together this is so beautiful check it
out and so if you're if you're on
gamespot watching live or on twitch
watching live throw in a question yeah
Alexa has had some information regarding
the the up the HD update hmm I know the
original really well so hopefully
between the two of us will have answers
for your questions its homeworld going
to have multiplayer I think we know the
answer is yes yes so the home world
multiplayer will launch alongside the
single player in beta which they're
going to tweak it live as they go
they'll be working on it seeing how
balancing will work they obviously have
to make entirely new servers because
with the game spy shut down all of the
old homeworld sir Oh games by homework
servers homeworld servers were [ __ ] up
looks like there's only a few guys left
here can you click on one unit just
click on one and then maybe hit F on the
keyboard
and then zoom in yeah there we go that's
what I wanted to see I wanted to see see
that I'm glad that the old control
Stewart oh yeah there's so much to all
my memories of the key bindings should
be look at this this is beautiful ways
he's about to die actually if anyone
wants to watch the ship just blow up I'm
doing ok so somebody asking how the HD
graphics compared to the original I
guess that's a question for me um this
is this is a hard one because i have you
know i don't i don't play home world
every day and and of course the problem
with with memories yeah now I didn't
play home world last year homeworld two
specifically but which I still have
still had the disc I found the disc my
closet I was like I know what I'm doing
tonight but one of the things about
memories of games you love is sometimes
what you remember looks a little bit
better in your memory that it actually
did in real life so I'm almost afraid of
that but it is clear that the ships have
had updated textures if you zoom in
really close you can you can see very
easily that the textures are updated you
can also see that the backgrounds have
been updated as well which I loved and
the interface has been has been cleaned
up somewhat and as well the cutscenes
are now in you know and you know and the
high definition that we would expect so
i would say it definitely looks better
yeah the problem of course is the
homeworld and homeworld two are already
beautiful to look at to begin with and
so and so you may not notice the
differences straight away if you compare
your memory yeah with the new but what
I'm hoping to do over the next you know
once once i get the review code what I'm
really really hoping to do is very least
I don't know if I'll be able to find my
original copy of homeworld look at that
but i still have homeworld 2 and so if i
can
so good this is one of the problems yeah
a game that looks just good though a
strategy game I guess is that you get
distracted by zooming in and seeing the
really cool stuff and sometimes you you
are getting that you need to strategize
okay yeah I just made them all super
aggressive you know and maybe you know
this Alexa do you know if anything's
been done for the soundtrack I have to
imagine I do now you do know so I so
Chris gearbox at pax aus and they told
me that the Paul risk it works Paul
risky risky risky policy a had the
original tapes for the original homework
soundtracks for me by the way I should
probably remember to turn my phone down
haha so we so what gearbox did is
gearbox went to him and had him took the
original tapes and completely retooled
the soundtrack to get into the game so
it's the original soundtrack but the
audio quality is to clean it up that's
great yeah it's and clean up the whole
thing's been cleaned up did it mmm this
is what I like about home road though
that was like a really beautiful like
almost a beautiful wash its zen-like to
watch it it's a bit you have to be very
careful because while the initial the
initial objectives that you get in the
game or are very doable they're very
doable they focus an RTS tradition they
focus on small groups of units and and
not a whole lot of fancy you know
needing to deal with you know with a lot
of rock paper and scissors going on
there's not a lot of need to deal with
your economy at this stage it's just
here's your units make some stuff and
throw it in yeah and and let it happen
but that changes as the game goes on
homeworld is it can be quite difficult
especially if you're used to playing
strategy games they like Starcraft and
you and you know you're you're trying to
get a handle on how to utilize the 3d
space its space again so we can really
see when you get a chance there we go
this
is really the plan you know obviously a
lot of stuff is still happening on a 2d
plane that you can you can kind of see
there but as the game continues you will
need to utilize 3d space a little bit a
little bit different oh yeah definitely
it'll ask you to it'll ask you to move
like up that way last things down I
while I'm waiting for my Salvage
Corvette to come back with some stuff
from the probe i am going to harvest
some resources so here's my little
resource collector what's this hello
that's something coming out of
hyperspace oh that's one of my favorite
sound effects in all of games forever
get it is the sound of and don't forget
you've got an economy you might be able
to build some spilled some stuff yeah I
might be able to get some junk from this
thing go get it go there you go into
bill do you have any fighters or
Corvettes you can you can throw into the
mix I bet you've got my tears and let me
get another Salvage Corvette do I have
no I wouldn't I wouldn't well yeah be
salvaged I'm more worried about you just
living we get another research resource
collector so we've got a resource
collector resource collector and a
salvage Corvette on the way I'm gonna go
God shoot the crap out of the ship that
disappeared out of hyperspace haha Group
1 go get him now somebody was asking
about about the campaigns and and I
haven't played the remasters so
hopefully you'll be able to answer this
Alexa uh oh god it's so beautiful one of
the one of the most interesting things
about homeworld is the way units are
persistent so when you finish a campaign
mission you then go into the next
campaign mission not only needing to to
build more ships and get an economy
going again but you also bring with you
all of the ships that are still left
from your last mission is that still the
case yeah I mean it's the same game it
is the same game completely redone to
look beautiful they haven't tampered
with any of what made homeworld
homeworld and because players were so
unhappy that the
original mothership voice was not
present for homeworld 2 they brought her
back and had her we record all the
dialogue so she is also the voice of the
mothership in homeworld 2 is all I me I
just I took over your mouths for just a
second nowhere so we could see a little
bit of a little bit of close-up fund
this this isn't necessarily your best
whoa whoa not your best route if you're
actually trying to win a lot of the time
but I might want to want to get some
more our ships in there if we can yeah
another so if it's the same game that
also means that another thing that
doesn't you don't see enough of is
location-based damage so so there's a
lot of location baby i'm the most
powerful ships you'll be able to target
engines so that the thing can't get away
you'll be able to target all sorts of
systems on it beyond just like generic
attacking of the hull um but I'm worried
about your few Scouts that are left i'm
making some more promise i am she looks
do they come look they're popping out
scout squadron pop it out down here ah
her voice so for people that want one of
the great things about homeworld two you
know when we talked about sound and of
course side of it I'm on record as
loving sound immensely you might want to
build up a few I don't know I don't know
if you want to send them just a few but
I'm all out no I'm just saying you might
want to make sure you have more Scouts
before you send in the few that you have
I don't know up to you I'm Alex going
I'll let you do your I wish you do your
thing I'm being mean I'm being judgey
I'm know I've got a lot to read it i'm
playing my judge we do I've got a lot of
resourcing research resource units to
burn here complete so there's a pop
mount but speaking of sound like carrots
oh and sand story I love the story of
karen's the jet who is who is basically
the she she'ssort of your um I don't
know she's sort of like nice show damn
it is like she's Jesus she's a woman
who's been hooked up to you know to to
be
the computerized center of your mother
ship and it's it's all very sci-fi and
heartbreaking but also very personal and
I think I think the best science fiction
stories are the stories about people and
that's what you know star wars a new
hope that's that's what makes those you
know Star Wars great yeah it's not just
about space and stuff it's about people
and I you know I love when the game
makes it about people when it tells us
more about Karen's eject this story is
very heartbreaking this is capable
really Scout complete um somebody asking
if this is easy to play no bc me just
getting wiped out well to be fair you're
just sending in a bunch of you're just
sitting in a bunch of scalped one at a
time i know and maybe the Bears go one
by one so i'm judging i'm taking the
place of all the people in the chat that
might be wondering what's going on I
know what I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to just build us like a
fleet up i'm also out of reach oh you're
out of resources right now things are on
hold oh okay so it's not like supreme
cameria which when Supreme Commander
came out one of the most interesting
things that game did is allow you to go
into the negative with resources and it
just went really really slow this will
just be on hold until you have resources
ready underway go collect things friend
so but people ask you if it's easy know
the game's home world is not I mean at
this stage we're just we're we're in a
very easy girlie tooling around it and
Alexis just messing around while I judge
her lying it but the game does get hard
and you run into very interesting
situations as I mentioned before the you
know the units are you know they carry
over from mission to Mission and
sometimes you find yourself having been
wiped out and again and you go into the
next mission and there's that mad
scramble to get things moving so that
you don't run into trouble yeah oh yes I
can't build anything yet
and and I've mentioned this before but
there's an incredible danger that
happens which is that you can get lulled
by the visuals which are just so it is
what does happen take a look at the
mothership well while we wait here's my
my you salvaged car that we're going
home mothership here's the mothership
again so she and that's the voice of
Karen sujet controlling the mothership
so hey Scout squadron complete yeah you
can rotate the camera literally just
putting possible numbers of angles here
there's look it's funny because there
are little little touches that mean so
much it's like there's be you know we're
going to create like when you when you
start the mission there's the initial
part where you launch all your ships you
know you'd think that you would start
and everything would just be sitting
there waiting to go and whatever but you
have that moment where you start the
mission you actually have to launch them
and they all come from out the bay you
can see the bay there on the side where
it's worth all white on the mothership
yeah we're all the light is coming from
are you going all I think I'm like let's
go balls to the wall so here all my
scouts hanging out waiting we're asking
how long the campaign's where I'm trying
to remember their long yeah my you know
my memory is that they were they were
substantial which is appropriate because
you know as good as multiplayer is in
RTS is just in general I would venture
to say that actually it was the and I'm
gonna get your other little group down
there going and now maybe we've got go
now avenge your father's death on the
the enemy mothership and then hit F and
then zoom in and let's let's let's watch
it be destroyed it's a little babe this
is get that get that awesome nebula on
banana back totally actually it just
looks like a galactic plane maybe look
at then we'll just wash things happen
this is
and you can really tell when you start
looking at this you oh my god here they
come here they come you can see how the
visuals haven't have been updated you
can see the you know the new textures
everything looks you know a little dirty
little worn and here we go here we go
that out somebody asking about adjusting
game speed I don't know that you can
adjust games me I would want to yeah you
can't you can it's not like a turn-based
game where it's like things get boring
you want to speed it up or anything and
I think I'm done with these asteroids
over here there's somebody asking about
the ships have a first-person camera
they don't they just have that really
close up third person unless gearbox has
added something and they have not
assembly under way go building three
more copy everyone go you should move
you should move the mothership again
let's let's see if we can get the
mothership in it that this mothership
will be will be dead before that happens
but the mother ship moves really slow
yeah she's moving but she's not moving
very very slowly she's not moving very
quickly sorry people talking about local
resources exhaust about cataclysm and
cataclysm as far as i know is not part
of this package no is now but maybe
we'll be lucky and your box will update
that as well resource is exhausted we
examine the resources cataclysm I'm
looking a bind here I've exhausted all
of my resources to make more to make
more Scouts and this ship up here is
just eating me alive have you have you
done any research next time you you you
bring in some some stuff you should
maybe research the Interceptor mm-hmm
and get things moving along a little bit
more I mean you could I mean at this
stage I think you're not really in any
danger you could probably you could just
probably keep pumping out scouts yeah
but I'm not getting
any damage yeah I need to fight
hostilities what is this oh it's like
the broken ship I have an idea back it
up if nothing's salvaged for heaven's
sake yeah I'm Salva I'm gonna salvage it
where's my Salvage collectors this is me
silently judging Alexa I'm sorry loudly
I'm totally loudly judging Alexa as she
plays Oh feel free I'm i am still
getting my bearings but this game is
friggin awesome you know it was really
slow oh god goodbye Scouts you were
great fro I'm into the end you can use
the mothership to to attack and you'll
probably be fine but that's going to
take forever do we have some we gotta
get some resources coming in do you how
many resource collectors do you have out
there you can also I don't know if you
have one you can also set up the you
know set up the unit out there that you
can deliver the resources to so that you
don't have to send into the mothership
but I don't know if you have one of
those I don't think I do this is like
the second mission in the game we're
very early on and my little guys went
over there the mothership if i recall
currents it can it can defend itself but
it's not going to last forever yeah you
can target other units with the
mothership but
but in case is it is not meant to be an
attack vessel I like that you have it
set up on auto launch I have to admit I
usually like to launch it myself because
I just think there's something more epic
about doing it that way for some reason
hmm yeah so you can like build stuff and
then you do it's all very slow going
yeah but you have your interceptor
research going no I do not wait so I got
a lot of fighter chassis going all right
yeah you have to build that you have to
I can make two with the resources that I
have it's good to do maybe you only you
only do only research I only do it once
that's only do one so this little guy
over here is approaching this I'm
wondering if you know dr. sell salvage
Corvette oh he booked him yeah OOP see
what he can get was a smart idea just
listen to the background it's just like
oh yeah that's the where you learn some
I saying does this game use the same
place the sins of a solar empire no
those are what did I do oh you're under
attack girl I know we need to you need
to get some units going you get get get
a couple interceptors in there come on I
can only make I can only make two
can do it just get them going you at
least a start and what's Ron Ron
interceptor complete mothership report
other set secure my interceptors
mothership where is it I'd leave them
there for now I I would now be a little
what are no stop what are the diamond
units you've got there those are
resource collectors why aren't they
collecting resources cuz I'm done look
at all them there's no there's no
resources left it says the guy said he
said exhausted all local resources so
I'm boned yeah I think that's probably
uh target confirmed go get them oh god
no please go away yeah I think you're in
trouble I'm in trouble next time I'm
yeah I'm gonna yank the keyboard the
mouse away from you you sure I'm me no
no I appreciate your tutelage my
tutelage cuz i don't i don't know how
long do we my Salvage are vectors along
40 in may on my salvage car that
exploded um well let's at least look at
the things up close it hit that ft and
zoom there we go and let's say I mean if
they're gonna they're gonna die at least
make the death pretty right the point is
we want you guys to see like just how
much has been done to like make this
look just like completely new yeah I
don't think any of it I don't think we
were out we were out to look like good
III don't think looking like a good home
world player was played the goal anyway
was really just to see the it really was
to see the visuals and see how this and
see how the update was looking at yeah
it's looking honestly looking mighty
effing fine yeah no it looks great where
are you going you're sucking up soon oh
good
he's looking at stuff they're chasing
all right got one I had to probe so I
don't want if it was one that was
beautiful well the thing is they were
they were focusing on the probe not on
you so you might actually be able to
pull this off I might it's gonna like a
really good close-up fight check this
out look at those light trails and it
leaves like yeah so beautiful I mean
that was always a book there you go not
one of mine that was under that I was
one of them that was always one of the
aspect aspects of of the original was
the light trails always looked great
well wait a minute where are they coming
from space hey I like where's my mom my
mommy ship may be in trouble we go back
here yeah all of these like we mined all
the asteroids i think i'm going to ask
this guy to retire the probe oh hey
moving to intercept there we go so
they're fighting right now and here are
my resource collectors just lined up and
waiting for his face and see if there
are any other places where you can send
them there you go what is over here this
is that's the enemy there's a cluster
over here you're all d yes sir or use
yeah you're you're bound yeah I'm early
enough in the game I am no no I'm early
enough in the game that like this is not
an issue but like look at that what
happened what's going on over in that
fight are you is there they're going to
come come after the mothership Oh
everyone's dead we all took each other
out in a blaze of glory do we want to
show off the original homeworld for oh
you mean homeworld 2 does this come with
the original like can you see the
originals visuals yeah and you're out
well then yeah
let's go back and let's look at think I
have to jump out of here though and
we'll see the computer so oh crap sorry
darn it yay so this is the game comes
with home early mastered and it comes
with the classic version so let's just
take a look let's take a look Oh Ciara
so the beloved Sierra which I think are
still officially alive and part of
Activision now but Sierra of course not
just it wasn't just home world that was
Sierra was King's Quest and actually the
original publisher of half-life yeah
counter-strike and so forth homeworld is
not a 4x people are asking if home runs
before exit is not a 4x how does not it
is a much more traditional real-time
strategy game that also happens to be
sentenced yes I'm trying to think of the
other stuff single player so look at
this yeah I know right let's uh go ahead
and start the start the new game and
let's take it at the beginning so we can
see the opening cutscene hey oh just
press Start look at this as a funny here
we go yeah it's check out the the low
res cutscenes
the thing is it was beauty was still
beautiful a satellite detected an object
under the sands of a great bedroom even
though audio is sort of like you know
rolling on up I love this shot right
here this shot always gets me it really
it really communicates the loneliness
you know the hugeness of the starship
the loneliness of the environment yeah I
think that you know I think that I know
the gearbox got gearbox purchase VIP
when the chq when THQ auctioned off all
of us assets gearbox purchase homeworld
and I honestly think that they've done a
really great job of making of taking
home worlds instead of making like
homeworld 2015 or something they think
they did a really great respectful thing
by sort of officiating the classic and I
think this will introduce it to a whole
new audience of people that maybe never
picked it up before I mean what I'd
really like to see I really would like
to see your homeworld 3 of course a lot
of people would and maybe this will be
this will be the chance but I'd love to
see some of those you know some of those
relic guys be part of that but it you
know it they've moved on to other things
and I I don't think we're going to see a
homeworld 3 and I well actually we might
gearbox might where you might pick up
that as a loan issue am I am sign that
banner strike um I'll never get to seen
impossible creatures to that's that's
really sad
one of their would one of my favorite
stories about relic is the story of
impossible creatures to which was
original sure impossible creatures
originally was called Sigma and then
they ended up getting sued because
something else was using both the word
Sigma college and they ended up changing
the name of the game who had herself
permanently injured by his our colony
ship as its living core the sad he is
now Fleet command oh he's now in a
mortal space lady the promise of the
guide stone oh I forgot they're making
ship breakers airmanship occurs
homeworld is that an official homeworld
it's a perfect I thought for some reason
I thought ship breakers wasn't
officially homeworld for some reason
shipbreakers is a spiritual successor
right um going back to the multiplayer
beta yeah like that will be that will be
available when people get the people get
the game here's the old mothership yep
and here we go with the great use of a
choral version of Samuel Barber's Adagio
that uses the word that uses the Anya
stay as the text
so yeah just like look at like this and
like compared to like to what your boxes
it's pretty amazing now looking back on
it it's funny because that's what I was
saying about memory how this looks kind
of like what my memory says home world
looks like but I'm like memory and and
reality are very often in pretty much
every way different so you're actually
you'll be doing the review for this game
yum yeah as soon as we get the review
code i'll be doing in a long time
longtime homeworld lover um like I said
last year I dug out my my disk I don't
think I did it on purpose i was i was
cleaning and I painted and as I was
cleaning out the closet I came across
like huge piles of disks and this was
one of the games i stuck in the i stuck
in the drive it took some homeworld 2
was it took some doing i had to to mess
with it a little bit to get it to run
properly because it would it would do
things like you know i would only see
like a like a little bit of the game on
my screen like it would stretch beyond
my screen look like that yet though
vikas in the the twitch chat is saying
that that ship breakers is now
officially homeworld oh that's super
bowl awesome I wonder how many how many
people will pick up will be picking up
homeworld for the first time with
homeworld remastered a lot I bet I mean
there was there's never there hasn't
been a good way to buy it for a long
time like you couldn't get it through
you know a legitimate purchasing source
so maybe you'd be lucky enough to be in
a game stuff for a Walmart somewhere and
yeah see the CD case sitting somewhere
but yeah after the hero says it will be
his first time and very exciting to get
to play a classic like this like I said
original homeworld one of my top 10
games of all time
homeworld 2 how much part of my is part
of a little bit of part of my gamespot
history um because it was one of those
it was a game that had gotten up back
when we had a component scores when we
scored you know just construction by
Bill gameplay graphics sound etc it
homeworld two had a perfect 10 in the
graphics and back you know I mean even
now like when you spend a lot of money
on video cards one of my favorite things
to do would be back when I was just a
fan go to gamespot do a search for all
the things that got tens in visuals and
then just buy those thanks because I
mean I was a graphics [ __ ] who are
funny this looks exactly how I remember
it don't I different that's because we
are looking at the original the original
original appears original before we have
before we head out we can't really show
you a lot since again coming out soon
but before we duck out on you will go
back and just show you the new one again
just so you can get a yeah let's go bad
idea and let's let's do the very opening
again and look at and people can judge
all God seem yes I maybe occasionally
play I am bread no one judge me oh I've
been judging you this whole time hmm
press H but no I mean not now don't
press any of course let's go to the
mission 1 we can't show that one we
can't it's on our restrictions and only
show certain ones yeah so gearboxes
politely asked us to not show too much
so you guys have something to look
forward to when you get it but this is
what we can show you we want to make
sure you guys get the full impact of how
much work has gone into this and see
check it out look how different the
mothership looks look at that look at it
look at the fact that it's not all
aliased and gross Yeah right look at
this like look at the like the front of
it I
like we saw in the beginning it was all
sort of like grainy and like everything
is smooth all the ships are launching
again my favorite thing is to do the
manual launch it always feels like I'm
more of a commander that way commander
Kevin I yeah and it's it's interesting
because I feel like I feel like it's
time for the the realtime strategy genre
to really make a comeback there was a
time when every other pc game that came
out scene seemed like it was an RTS yeah
although I'm talking about you know 2002
2003 you know we had all sorts of games
that nobody even now remembers mm-hmm
but I feel like there's there's a
resurgence coming I mean stark I don't
include starcraft 2 because I feel like
whatever Blizzard does sort of exists in
its own thing it's you know you know
starcraft 2 is starcraft 2 but now i
feel like there really is a resurgence
we've got Greg ooh yes just get out for
example and I feel like it's time it's
time for games like this where you know
there was more or less equal footing for
an economy and equal footing for for
battle and you know for a long time
strategy games were coming out they were
only they were so battle focused that in
a lot of cases resource collection and
base building was just dropped entirely
now there's not really base building in
in home world but there's certainly I
mean the mothership is your base yeah
and it is your your single base for well
not completely single base but is your
main base for constructing units there
are other units that spawn units but
yeah now this is like super this is just
super relaxing like take an afternoon
make yourself some tea and just you know
play homeworld couple hours research
research sip complete new yet get the
construction get your complete move move
over oh I don't think you have
yeah just get your interceptors any set
Oh constructor little crazy too here's
my new resource collector coming out the
ship comment out the ship receptor
squadron complete hello but anyway now
we're just doing the same thing that we
did before now we're hanging out yeah so
this is what we wanted we wanted to give
you a chance to kind of compare the
original through the remaster so we
could really see just how drastic that
difference was where are we I respa
don't like oh yeah I think it about
wraps it up yes waiting for for the
go-ahead from Josh back there to see if
that's if that's indeed where we're at
yeah they're ready yeah this is this is
uh no this has been a really emotional
very sweet journey sorry I didn't win
I'm still sort of learning out of it was
okay you're not you're not a strategy
game player and you actually asked me
Kevin do you want to drive and I hahaha
no women drivers am i right because no
that's not what I Matt's not what I
meant to no don't pull that one on me um
but it was more that I haven't you know
I haven't touched it and I've been
waiting for the I've been waiting for
the full version to keep in your hand it
might give my hands Queen so I can leap
in um but next time all yeah next since
I'm the strategy guy next time I'll jump
in and and and take the reins well I
don't think you'll be disappointed this
is a super awesome game it looks really
cool februari 25th it'll be on Steam
multiplayer launch is the same day so
grab your friends exciting times I am
way sykes now somebody get out there and
by hedge ammonia so that we can get a
hedge ammonia remastered and maybe maybe
all the space RTS will make a comeback
maybe they won't yep thank you for
watching
you